c'est ce samedi qu'a nouveau vaccin
contre le coc vite 19 fait son entrée en
france et peut contribuer à booster la
campagne de vaccination mais à peine
arrivé sur le sol français voilà que ce
vaccin fait déjà débat si son usage à
dose unique est une première dans cette
campagne de vaccination son efficacité
elle est sujette à certaines des
réticences mais alors que savons nous
réellement de ce vaccin déjà utilisée
aux états unis est confronté à de réels
suspicions d'effets secondaires
à l'heure actuelle quelques deux cent
mille doses de vaccin johnson & johnson
ont déjà été livrées en france destiné
aux plus de 55 ans il pourra être
administrée par les infirmiers libéraux
par les médecins mais aussi par les
formations
nous attendons le vaccin nous avons fait
la demande
comme indiqué par la dgs et nous
espérons le recevoir dans les jours qui
viennent
quand on va se passer des livraisons de
2,2 ce fameux vaccin est prévu pour pour
l'instant vu les indications qu'on a
eues la semaine dernière commande et un
flacon par semaine livrables la semaine
suivante
donc on n'est pas livré dans la même
semaine ensuite moi n'étant pas
titulaire de l'officine j'ai quand même
mon diplôme de pharmacien engagé j'ai
décidé dans l'exercice de ma profession
de ne vacciner que des gens pour
lesquels je peux accéder à leur dossier
on a des patients intéressés parce qu'il
ya une seule injection
ce qui est quand même beaucoup plus
pratique beaucoup plus motivant à la à
la vaccination
il n'y a pas d'écart trop importants
comme il y en a avec astrazeneca
je ne veux pas prendre le risque de
vacciner des gens qui ont des
traitements chroniques type
anticoagulant type diabète type que je
ne connais pas donc je veux qu'ils aient
un état de confiance entre le patient et
moi dans l'acte vaccinal vos passions
que vous avez sélectionné son courant
des effets secondaires qui ont été
annoncées au courant parce que c'est mon
rôle de leur indiquer il y à un risque
vous le savez je vous explique
et après c'est à moi de leur donner
confiance et d'être dans la pédagogie
son efficacité si l'on s'en réfère aux
dires du fabricant américain il serait
efficace à 80% il grimperait même à 100%
contre les hospitalisations et décès de
quoi être rassuré serait même
respectivement été casse de 81 et 87 %
contre les variants
africains et brésiliens alors vous
l'aurez compris ce vaccin pourrait être
la star des sérums détrônant ceux des
laboratoires pfizer modern man ou encore
astrazeneca
mais tout cela c'est sans compter les
nombreux effets secondaires révélé sur
des dizaines de patients aux états unis
outre atlantique en effet une dizaine de
cas de thrombose cérébrale rares ont été
observés autrement dit des caillots
sanguins ce qui a valu au géant de
l'industrie pharmaceutique d'être dans
le viseur des autorités sanitaires
malgré un scénario qui rappelle à s'y
méprendre celui de l'astra zeneca dont
l'utilisation avait été stoppée par de
nombreux pays
l'agent se repaît des médicaments a
toutefois recommandé sa livraison et son
utilisation
jugeant la balance bénéfice-risque
largement favorable aux patients paris
devrait recevoir jusqu'à 8 millions de
doses d'ici la fin du mois de juin de
quoi accélérer la campagne de
vaccination sur l'ensemble du territoire
malgré des doutes persistants qui risque
encore de ralentir la campagne de
vaccination